hot mugshot guy Jeremy Meeks his wife  Melissa says their marriage is over  [Music]  the 38 year old nurse is speaking out  after her felon turned model husband was  photographed getting extremely cozy on a  yacht off the coast of Turkey with  Topshop heiress Chloe green in a recent  interview Melissa told the Daily Mail  that she felt quote humiliated when  photos of her husband kissing the 26  year old socialite surfaced online she  revealed she and Jeremy talked about  divorce and agreed the marriage is over  I'm a little nervous but more excited  Jeremy rose to fame after his smoldering  mug shot took the internet by storm and  has been married to Melissa for eight  years he has reached out to Meeks rep  for comment  [Music]  you